is
kindness a weakness i got a great
message from one of my youtube viewers
love you guys
who wrote in asking about one of my
videos where i talked about
i like to hire nice people i it's true i
like to hire nice people
often put that on the job description
that i like hiring nice people
and she's worried that she's too nice a
person so let me read what she wrote she
wrote in to say i love that your company
hires nice people my last job i was told
in the interview you seem like a nice
person and that's cute
and all but what what can you offer this
company
i got the job and i went from positive
to negative and sad i realized i was
absorbing all their bad energy and
ideals
i'm struggling to find a new job now and
i'm and i find myself
wondering if being nice has anything to
do with it yet it felt like poison to my
soul so stain was not an option i have a
question how do i
have my kindness not taken for weakness
what am i doing wrong
here's my view you're not doing anything
wrong okay you're just not working with
the right companies
when i say i like hiring nice people i
put that in my job description
some people they read that and they
laugh and they say
this is stupid come on you like hiring
nice people who writes that in
in a job description that's stupid i
don't want you working out my company
that's cool man if you don't like it
don't apply
they're gonna self-eliminate and then
people like you
who felt like you are a genuinely nice
person you're gonna read that and say ah
finally i can't wait to apply there
that's the difference because you're
never going
to be happy with your work you're never
going to feel fulfilled
with what you're doing if you're forcing
yourself to work in a culture
that doesn't fit you if you're forcing
yourself to work with people who are not
nice
and you're super nice it's never going
to work
i hate working with people who aren't
nice it just
it drives me nuts and i love working
with people who are nice
so make it clear these are the types of
people that we're looking for
that's the company you need to find and
it's not just about being nice it's
whatever
whatever characteristic you have
whatever personality trait
you have whatever you believe in you
want to work at a company
that respects and honors that if you're
really competitive
you want to work at a company where
everything is really competitive
you wouldn't have fun probably at a
government job that's super boring
that wouldn't be for you because it's
not competitive enough
you're going to be happy so if you're
nice you got to go out and find
nice companies people who talk about
this people who live this
so you're not doing anything wrong you
don't need to change yourself
you just need to find a culture at a
company that fits you and it's worth
spending the time to do it right so you
don't get locked into one bad job
after another bad job after another bad
job you want a company
who sees you as being nice
as an asset will pay you more for that
than a company that says uh you're nice
i don't know what you can do for the
business
so don't change who you are change the
company that you work for
believe for those of you watching you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up below
you want to see more like this you have
a comment you have a question leave it
below in the comment section i'll make a
video response
and if you like the channel subscribe so
you can see more videos just like this
thank you so much
and i'll see you soon